okay our next game Olli chest from long
way huh well you could have gone for
French - whence one move earlier so I
can easily do that now so yeah this is
some quite interesting sideline which
isn't played very often but some got the
advantage that often white players don't
have any clue how to play against it the
main idea is to really quickly get in
Bishop h6 a6 to exchange the bishop yeah
I need to react with h5 to that I can't
allow him to push further now I can
really exchange the bishop okay in this
case he can also take with the pawn so
you won't get the really dreadful Square
and c4 but so it's an interesting
position
you know I need to I'm not quite sure
what to put the pieces here
yeah seems he wants to go Bishop III
which certainly looked some like a
logical idea yeah I think I need to
close the some diagonal idea now would
be to do you really insist on opening
they're interesting hmm
this could be very dangerous position
for me but yeah I wanted to take instead
of closing even more to to get some
potential counterplay here on D form or
now with the idea of putting the night
there
yeah I want to make sure that this night
is really covering the diagonal here one
ongoing issue here is that I have
problems with just counselling because
of a stupid-looking move like Queen g5
and then um I simply lose the edge porn
I get I think maybe in this case I have
Queenie 7 if he takes on h5 if I like I
can take h4 hmm might be dangerous
anywhere but I can't play without the
rook the whole game so maybe maybe try
that yeah maybe it didn't really
appreciate Queenie 7 Queen h5 q h4
should be really okay for me I think an
end game most likely it's okay for me
because the Knights are are pretty okay
in this kind of structure and he tries
to go to 256 here yeah better take off
Queens now
yeah okay he can go there but still I
have fun move like on Roxie - and now I
can also go to f5 with one night maybe
in order to encourage him to exchange
okay I think now he has to exchange the
rukon c8 himself
okay they like sir to sacrificed
exchange here hmm surprising but I guess
I can also take on c1 now I don't have
to allow the postpone here in this
position I also have 194 technically
yeah 94 on rook c8 rook c8 c1 is saying
so right now on I don't I don't see a
playable move at all
c5 is also hanging they cannot like that
yeah no no move yeah this went down
really quickly for why did what
certainly wasn't that bad um I think
throughout here the position maybe it's
about equal so difficult difficult
position I very much like my structure
it night on the six looks looks
irritating he just he just should go
there at this point also allowing him in
case of my knowledge for in case of this
maybe maybe just ninety six here now and
then it's got the chance to exchange my
night on five at least
yeah I like I like black in this
position but it's very difficult
yeah
you